It turns out that most prolines in
the T-Rex peptides identified by Asara
were actually modified version of
prolines called hydroxyprolines.
And in this segment,
we will talk about searches for
post-translationally modified peptides.
The central dogma doesn't mention it, but
many proteins are subject to a large
number of post-translational
modifications that are important for
cell-signaling and metabolic regulation.
In fact, most proteins
are post-translationally modified and
over 600 types of modifications
of amino acids are known today.
Some of them are extremely important, such
as phosphorylation, shown on this slide.
How does a modification
affect a peptide vector?
If you think about this, modification is
simply changing the mass of the amino acid.
If we limit ourselves to computational
analysis of modification and
a modification of mass "delta".
applied to an amino acid results
in adding data to its mass.
For phosphorylation, for
example, delta = 80.
For hydroxyproline in collagens,
it is equal to 16, and
for a modification of lysine into allysin,
it is equal to -1.
Therefore, modifications essentially
increase the number of letters
in the amino acid alphabet and
complicate peptide identifications.
In the beginning of this lecture, we looked
at the ideal spectrum of this peptide.
Let's now look at how this
ideal spectrum changes
if we introduce a modification
on this peptide.
Here's this modification on C+16,
and this modification affects
two prefix peptides and,
in fact, three suffix peptides.
So, the ideal spectrum has
changed in this case.
But please note that we don't know in
advance what is the mass of modifications,
and we don't know on which amino
acid this modification is residing.
Let's also take a look at how
a modification affects a peptide vector.
In this particular example,
a modification of mass 3 on the i-th
amino acids essentially amounts
to inserting a block of 3
consecutive 0s before the i-th
occurrence of 1 in the peptide vector.
This is for
the modification of positive mass.
For a modification of negative mass,
-2 in this case,
the modification corresponds to
deleting the block of 2 0s
before the i-th occurrence
of 1 in the peptide.
And after we figure out how
modifications affect the peptide vector,
we are ready to formulate
the spectral alignment problem.
Before we do this, let's define
the notion of Variants_k(Peptide)
as the set of all modified variants of
Peptide with up to k modifications.
We want to solve the spectral alignment
problem, which is: Given a peptide and
a spectral vector,
find a modified variant of this peptide
that maximizes the peptide-spectrum
score among all
variants of the peptide with
up to k modifications.
Of course, there is a very simple solution
of this problem: We simply check all
possible peptides in the set
Variants_k(Peptide)
and see which of them has the maximum score.
But this will be too slow
because our more ambitious goal
is to solve the following
modification search problem:
Given a Spectrum and a Proteome,
find a peptide of a maximum score
against this Spectrum among
all modified peptides in the Proteome
with up to k modifications.
Obviously, to efficiently solve the
modification search problem, we need to
come up with a very fast algorithm for
solving the spectrum alignment problem.
And, if we figure out how to search for
modified peptides,
we will immediately be able to search for
mutated peptides as well
because the mutation search problem
results from simply substituting
the word modifications for
mutations, like shown in this slide.